but I really do want to get people talk
about quantum physics and multiverse and
like I'd really love to find a
paranormal researcher who's like a real
one at a university that doesn't treat
it like we entered the scary mansion the
door closed
oh then they'll run out screaming no I
mean like someone who's literally like
we've mapped all of these different
hotspots and found common factors such
as they're near a you know lead deposit
or something like that and like you know
trying to figure out what actually is
mm-hmm yeah I read something about how
it might be tectonic formations causing
ultra-low frequencies interesting which
cause humans to he'll hallucinate I
don't know I was something I read when I
was just doing like you know I have a
ghost I have a ghost video that I I
caught I have yes ghost what I have
audio of I walked into this old for in
Jersey actually it's in North Jersey and
on the shore it's an old bunker where
they you know mortar base where they
would shoot at ships and like 1908 or
something and I was there and these Park
Rangers came and opened the gate and
went in and then I forgot to lock the
gate and I'm with this group of people
and I was like I'm going in there and
they're like you're crazy and I'm like I
pull out my phone I hit record and I
just like I go in and I go deep into
this deep into this thing man and it is
like pitch black and it's freaky
and I don't hear anything yeah I didn't
hear anything the whole time I'm like
this is cool or as creepy I'm filming I
go out and I like go home and I show my
friends and we're like you know it's
like later on at night it's quiet and
watching this video and I hear this
giggle I'm like what was that giggle my
friends were like that's giggling
someone giggled at you and it was right
when I say it's creepy in here and then
you hear but you to notice it when in
heaven bro if I heard giggling like
right when I'm like this is creepy in
here if I heard that giggle I would have
been out I would have been gone dude but
I didn't hear it it was not something
that I heard until after when I heard
the video I put it on my youtube channel
like you can go out go check out my
channel it's this creeped me out that's
the name of the video now what's even
crazier is like six months go by I'm
showing everyone like oh listen to this
ghost giggle at me you know giggle at me
and and I I was showing this friend of
mine and we're
Lane we're laying there and it's really
really quiet and we're watching it and
you hear a woman screaming in like the
white noise like 15 seconds after the
game so you didn't notice it I didn't
even I didn't even notice this this
screaming and once I heard the scream I
cannot like unhear it it's crazy but
it's it's on my youtube channel you can
we used to we'll do a segment on it
maybe well I mean maybe well maybe we'll
do another segment out because I think
we already got one with this yeah talk
about some ghost stories well I could
want to don't play it for you and see
what you think so the house I grew up in
mm-hmm we had a bunch of creepy stuff
happen yeah and I look these are just
you know old stories but I was told that
the woman who sold it to my parents I
was like three when we moved in he was
like her husband died she was a widower
and so she moves out and we had some
creepy stuff happen so first maybe it
maybe was a glitch the dryer would turn
itself on really and maybe and but it
was the kind where you'd pop the thing
out like you know you ever see those
things where you like yeah
you set you turn it to the time and then
pull it foot pull it out oh but you had
it physically pull it out yeah yeah you
know what I got a better idea
let's tell about let's like about the
ghost stories to Miami house okay do you
remember what happened with the the
washing machine
no what happened the watchman okay I
don't even know it was us there's
there's a couple crazy stories ah so I
lived in Miami for because I was working
for fusion in Miami I I don't even
remember exactly how I was like Adam
come on down come across we want to do
something like this right yeah we were
actually we actually actually we tried
we right that's true yeah and so now
we're actually doing it so Adam would be
chilling in the living room it's hard to
explain the LAT of the house but let me
just let me just picture this when you
walk in the front door to the right of
you is a living room and then too if you
keep going straight you end up in it was
the kitchen right yeah it was like the
dining hall so so think of it this way
the house is a rectangle and you're
entering from the broad side right lean
it maybe it's really hard to explain but
the the the the the right side of the
house was where the living room was at
and then when you walk forward yeah
there's like a dining space
yeah and there were stairs to the right
the living room the kitchen was the left
and to the left of the kitchen was the
laundry area right so Adam is plenty you
were you were playing destiny you know
you were sitting vaping playing destiny
yeah minding your own business just like
you know just going after was the bad
guy I don't remember got a goal call or
whatever so here's what happened main
bad guy I come downstairs and I go into
the laundry room and I throw my laundry
in you I close the lid and turn it on
mm-hmm and walk away I go into I think I
was in like the kitchen chillin you go
and then I go into the living room where
you're at and I'm like and a half an
hour of the laundry will be done half an
hour goes by I get up and go to the
laundry room and it spits almost
pitch-black it's faint light and I walk
up to the washing machine and okay I'm
looking for the washing machine it's a
big white machine so even when it's dark
you'll see it yeah I don't see it and
what I see is just just blackness and so
I reach my hand out reach my hand in I
touch water whoa whoa whoa wait what I'm
and then I go over and turn the light on
the washing machine was open but filled
to the top and so then I was like I was
like I got mad yeah I'm like who who
walked over here and opened the machine
in because it said it couldn't finish
she didn't spin right and I yelled to
you and I was like yo did you just come
in here and turn this off and you were
like dude I was sitting next to eat like
sitting here the whole time yeah and I
was like dude what that's weird and as
soon as that happened it's when my
brother Ryan was like bro I didn't want
to tell you this because I assumed you'd
think I was crazy how I remember this
conversation he was like I just figured
you'd think I was crazy but now that
this happened to you dude there's been
weird stuff happening in this house yeah
and here's the thing about that house
the people who rented it to us it was
like kind of falling apart
yeah and they were gone like they were
like we don't take care of it they lived
in upstate but it was like there it was
our relatives who had passed or
something I can't really remember yeah
yeah but I know that they were alike
we'll take anything and they'd rent it
to us super cheap and was his massive
property yeah so my brother ends up
telling me stories about the first which
was not super creepy but he was like
dude so
from behind from behind where the living
room is the stairs go up and then after
up the stairs you can walk all the way
down the length of the house to the
master room which has its own bathroom
yeah and Ryan was like when you're gone
and I'm here by myself
because like I would go on trips I'd be
working for fusion so either I Drive to
work he was like dude I can hear someone
closing doors and I can hear someone
using the toilet but nobody but the
first the first thought was like who's
breaking into the house we're in the
middle of nowhere it's like a big farm
property that hallway creeped me out man
I would walk down that hallway and I'd
get flashes of someone looking at me
from you know those you know you the
roof was right there so like if you were
standing on the roof
you could look right inside the window
like you know you're right there in you
know so I would walk down the hallway
and I'd get these flashes of someone
looking at me on the other side of the
window like that sitting on the roof
looking at me but that's where the
escalation and I just be like I'm gonna
keep moving keep going down the hallway
so so so this is actually where so so
Ryan's stories about like the doors
closing and everything I'm kind of like
combined with what just happened with
the washing machine mm-hmm dude you got
to understand nobody was in the house
who went to the wash machine and opened
it I couldn't I closed it to turn it on
No so I I was like did I leave it opened
it on if I left it open yeah I was on I
closed it and hid it and walked away so
Ryan said after he said about the
bathroom and everything he was like dude
it's not just that we had a room that
was on the first floor all the way to
the left on the opposite end of the
building that no one used no one right
and Ryan said when he would be in the
kitchen he would hear a faint noise
coming from the empty room and he would
walk over and he said it sounded like
there was a pane of glass and on the
other side were two old women having a
conversation and it freaked him out yeah
I never knew her DP and so it cleaned it
as like you it sounded like and he was
and he was freaked and were and and and
he was like if I was worried that if I
told you about this
it would become reality no no you you'd
think I was nuts right and I was like
dude it's not just it it was like the
the bathroom thing yeah I'd be upstairs
and I'd hear doors close so downstairs
yeah and my thought was somebody was
breaking in because I'm like if somebody
you know but no one ever broke in we
never had any thefts nothing ever
happened
but Ryan so what we ended up doing is
actually it's funny Ryan we ended up
turning into like a sketch we just made
it totally turned it into a total humor
thing yeah yeah all right I was freaked
out for a while
yeah maybe man yeah the washing machine
story so so actually yeah going back I
thought that was you know an interesting
story to talk about but going back to
the house I grew up in mm-hm I remember
a few really specific moments that
freaked me out when I was little the
washing machine would turn on I'm sorry
the dryer yeah it would just be on and
empty and I'm like maybe it's broken but
no someone pulled the switch up another
thing that happened to me was I was home
I believe us by myself and here the way
the way we had our agent set up was way
like a laundry room I'm gonna where we
would throw all of our laundry in front
of the washer and dryer and it was like
a pile of like pile up like yeah we'd
fill up our hampers and then we went in
the basement and just like drop it just
drop it just drop it it was a big area
for mom to do the laundry pretty much
know that we went to do laundry
ourselves but it was like we put it down
there and periodically you know I was
like my mom and my sister we did some
laundry but then we'd go down there and
like that's where all the laundry was
yeah he has a Southside Chicago life and
one day I went down with some of my
laundry and threw it in the washing
machine and started it up and then I
realized I left some laundry in my room
that I really wanted to wear and this
was when I was like probably you know 9
or 10 okay when I came back down the
sink next to the machine was running
full blast and then I just I walked over
and I looked at it and then I cuz then
they were there the light it was levers
so it's like the spigot had two levers
next to it left and right they go up and
down okay that's how it was yeah and it
was hot and cold and the cold was just
on full blast
spraying yeah and I literally was just
down there ten seconds before no one was
in the house you're by yourself yeah oh
that's creepy and so I go downstairs I
start laundry everything's fine I'm like
oh my shirt no shirt I want to wear I
ran upstairs ran back down and sprang
and I walked up to it like ha I turn it
off and then I got the heebie-jeebies
yeah
ran full speed up now haha there was a
bunch of other really weird stuff there
was one time I woke up and we had bunk
beds it was like it was like a futon bed
mm-hm so the bottom was a futon top was
it was a bunk bed and I was sleeping on
the futon part and I wake up and it's
like 2:00 in the morning but the room
had an odd glow to it yeah it seemed
like like something woke me up because
it was like a light blue like where was
the light coming from the floor okay and
I rolled over and looked and it looked
like the reflection of a pool on the
floor and I just rolled over and was
like hmm like terrified as well as a
little kid and interesting yeah so I
Kyra member these stories like I
remember these things happen mean I was
freaked out and I'm not crazy you know
you know and I think it's I think it's
always cool to talk about you know it's
why I really like paranormal stuff
because I have no idea what happened
yeah who knows what maybe maybe maybe
someone slipped some acid up in my my
food or something and I'm like whew and
I was 9 I doubt it it was some weird
stuff happened yeah and we had snow and
and other people in the house had crazy
stories to house in Miami story now it's
creeping me out cuz I yeah dude I I
swear someone was looking at me a couple
times well that's when hallway so so the
vibe man so you're talking about on the
balcony right
like snow no not on the balcony in the
front of the house
oh the like the awning yeah I got the
window walking from my room to your room
that hallway right down to the like or
the the jam room at that house was was
those windows on the left with that had
like roof the roof there you know yeah
that's the windows that I always like
the last one not the one near my room
but my room passing your room into the
jam room there's that window right there
that window I like constantly be like
these something's looking at me
something's out there looking at me
right now it I couldn't shake it the
whole time I was there when Ryan told
the story about hearing the old women
mm-hmm like muttering and said the glass
yeah like our reaction was to
immediately turn it into a joke about
90s commercials in Chicago where like
something weird happens in all Sonic
it's really excited and tells what the
lawn mowers or selling or something so
like I just find it funny that we're
like there's something crazy going on
man I swear I heard these like dude
someone [ __ ] what
somebody was messing with the washing
machine on this work somebody was
messing with the washing machine
wouldn't be a really funny comedy
routine and we're like yeah and though
he's do like we totally just like lose
our train of thought well that's good
that you were able to turn into comedy
because it could probably creep a lot of
people out dude yeah we should actually
we should actually come back to this
when we have a better plan to talk about
let's talk about it real ghost stories
and stuff and actually bring our
thoughts together cool and then you can
pull those videos I would love because
I've got you up we can pull up videos
right and play video because it's cool
man
if I lived I lived in a this house in a
part of Chicago yeah where we were
straight up told the previous owner
hanged himself in the basement well and
so we were all super excited because I
was like funny creepy man and and then
it went to his family who didn't think
that do with it because of it so they
sold it immediately they were like we
don't want this in our family yeah so we
ended up trying to do like EVP stuff I
don't want to I don't ever pretend
something magical happened yeah but we
did record stuff that creep that most
those creepy sounding we didn't hear
words yeah you know we we like looked
online how to do it and we have
microphones but we just heard like weird
noises yeah I'm always I'm always really
skeptical when I'm watching which I have
seen you know the I'm interested so
right you know because I don't know
that's why I don't play games with the
EVPs stuff yeah because you'll hear
someone look like listen it's recording
and I'll go and look like what did it
say it said it said please help me and
you're like it just sounded like I want
where I want
ah but we heard we heard creepy things
like and we were like whoa whoa that's a
zombie moan yeah like weird noises that
freaked us out I'm not I don't play this
parent what what does that face I'm just
curious if that would happen anywhere
you try it probably that's that's a
probably go saying like you know we
don't we I don't I don't play games it's
like I'm not gonna pretend like
something magical happened like the
little little fuzz balls and cameras
it's like but it also if you go near the
pyramids which are on you see like yeah
because there it's it's
you